de la onu hasta el himma rights watch
han prendido las alertas porque
consideran que el régimen de excepción
podría usarse para violar los derechos
humanos es factible esto
y en la práctica ya estaba ocurriendo
este día en cómo tuvo muy bien lo
mencionaba se suspendieron garantías
personales para cuatro derechos
en la práctica se implementado también
su cerco que limitan las circulaciones
determinadas durante el área
metropolitana limitando el derecho a la
circulación lo cual por supuesto
representa una vulneración un derecho
que no está contemplado en este texto
regulatorio en la práctica así puede
seguir ampliando las medidas que el
presidente exija a su asamblea hay que
recordar que es mayoritaria en este
momento el presidente domina la asamblea
legislativa pero no sólo esto tiene un
control del del judicial y también de
una fiscalía a través de la cual pre
impuestos rodolfo delgado fiscal general
de la república y buque lo defiende las
medidas diciendo que son para atacar a
las pandillas y ante el repunte de
homicidios que precisamente el fin de
semana pasado superaron los 80 luego del
régimen hubo un día con cero asesinatos
sirven esas medidas
es difícil saber si las medidas
implementadas bajo el marco del régimen
de decepción han sido la el motivo por
el cual hemos tenido en las últimas 24
horas según datos oficiales cero bases
de datos esto es muy difícil
determinarlo y porque es muy difícil
determinarlo porque hasta antes de este
repunte generado el último fin de semana
en el salvador donde vivimos alrededor
de 70 aspirados hemos tenido un periodo
de al menos un año y medio con una baja
letalidad en el país y no necesariamente
en el marco de un régimen de excepción
de manera que el análisis debería más
bien volcarse a cuáles son y cuáles son
más bien los puntos efe sostienen el
acuerdo entre pandillas y el gobierno
como presuntamente está revelado a
través de investigaciones periodísticas
y trans pernas del departamento del
tesoro de eeuu y como usted lo mencionó
el gobierno controla la mayoría de la
asamblea del sistema judicial y la
fiscalía muy brevemente que otras voces
hay sobre el régimen de decepción
bueno ahora mismo los ojos están puestos
sobre poder garantizar los derechos
humanos de la población en el marco de
estas medidas el presidente de la
república desde su cuenta en túnel ha
sido muy empático el de despreciar el
desprestigiar el la labor de organismos
internacionales en materia de derechos
humanos y por lo tanto los espacios de
control tenéis muy limitados el estado
está controlado y la instancia de
veeduría de derechos humanos a nivel
internacional pues comienzan a hacer
estar cerradas a través del discurso
público que era en nuestra función como
periodismo independiente
monitorear la implementación de estas
medidas